[Music]  [Music]  come yes I love you okay  [Music]  holistic rulers of prisons most unusual  punishments may write us a heart you're  born into it and then you're born in  prison you don't know what to do with  the fruit working on getting you out of  here what were you in for salt with a  deadly weapon now what you're gonna do  I'm trying to be a writer I'll teach  these kids not to make the same mistakes  I did  I got a carload of oxycontin need to be  up important by Friday can't do it  just not me no more when I wake up in  the morning I want to see you I don't  want to see that kid you know we don't  have nowhere else to stay not all Nazis  of the sea only the ones that stop you  from never fighting again make you a  loser  Mickey go back to us easy but you know  I'm running out of options out here  well the other moss is just served to  stranded  do I have to do for my son pay for  what's ahead  [Music]  study lab is over gotta go talk to mom  I'm not going anywhere